欢迎你学习白泽国际站运营实战系统课 同学们这节课 我们来讲一下
PC和APP端首页的介绍APP端的话 那么我们这次可能就不介绍你自己根据PC端的模板去对照的去学习就可以了
我们主要是讲PC端的首页的一些内容和一些重点的板块 那么为什么我们要强调介绍这个PC端的首页呢
因为这个首页代表着你不同流量的模块区分 以及你是怎样去获取流量的
因为我们在运营的过程中发现很多人其实对PC端首页都不太了解 也不知道流量是从哪里来的
所以说我们在操作店铺的时候就没有方向 没有头绪 那么通过掌握PC端各个板块的流量入口 我们就能够清楚我们的流量来自哪里
以及我们要怎样去做 才能够获得这些流量 才能够让店铺的效果更好
那么接下来我们就到后台看一下具体的内容 首先我们打开后台的时候 它是这样的一个界面的
他这里的话会分两个板块 第一个就是产品的板块 第二个就是制造商的板块 他在平台上会分两个流量的入口 不同的板块代表着不同的流量入口
比如说A商家可能从这个板块进入平台 也可能通过这个板块进入平台 所以说这两个板块里面都应该要包含我们自己的产品
才能够获得更多的流量 比如说你的产品B只在这个板块 那么A收这个板块的话你才能够出现 如果A收了这个板块的时候
是不是你B的产品就不可能在这里面出现
所以我们在布局店铺的产品或者是说运营店铺综合数据的时候 想办法让我们的店铺在这个板块有效果
在这个板块也能够拿到流量 那么你就相当于整个店铺会有两条流量渠道进入你的店铺 那么是不是你的流量会更加的大
是不是这个道理 那么我们这里还可以切换一下他的一个文字状态 我们把它变成中文
产品跟制造商 第一个这个板块的话 我们通常用关键值去收的 这些都是根据你之前收的内容
去给你推荐的 那么这里也是你常收的内容推荐的 这里还可以根据图片去搜索 比如说客户
他有一款产品 但是他想找同类的产品 那么他就把他图片放进来进行搜索 另外一个就是这里会有所有的内幕 客户也可以通过这些板块
这些内幕 我们常说的内幕曝光 比如说从这里进去 随便点个包印 这里面出现的产品呢 就是进到你的详细的内幕里面 比如说这个内幕 包印内幕 整个内幕的所有的流量端口都在这边 全部都在这里 下方这些是推荐 这些是领袖卖家 这里的实力都是非常强 非常牛逼的那些卖家 这里的话就是每一个板块都是一个场景
你只有符合条件的才能有机会进入这些场景进行展示 如果你不符合条件 那么你也是没办法进入这些场景
你看这些很多个板块 这个就是通过内幕进入他的板块了 有很多客户都是通过这个内幕去找自己内幕的
比如说有些客户他属于时尚潮流的 那么他肯定是会通过这些去查找的 也可能他在这里通过关键词去搜索 也会按照这种方式去找产品 所以说客户找产品的方式
是非常多的 我们要了解
更多的流量来源的局道 或者是说买家搜索的习惯 这样更有利于我们后期去布局店铺的产品和操作自动车
我们来看第1个首页就是这个板块 这个板块就是手胶图 手胶图的话他会有7个板块
这些板块通常都是流量
活动的一些板块给我们在这里推送
比如说你点进去之后 他就是一个大的板块 看到没有 这是阿里官方
给这些产品板块做引流的
这些会经常更换的 也就是这里的7张图会经常更换
换成不同的活动
有时候如果9月或者是3月
这些大处的时候
如果你获得一些比较好的资源的话 也会在这里为你单独的引流也有可能
那么下面就是这个板块经常浏览的一些历史
下面这个就是
热门榜单
榜单里面会有
爆款商品 热卖榜 好评榜
这个爆款榜单的话主要是根据
寻盘量来排序的 而热卖榜单根据的是你的
订单量
来排序的 好评榜根据你的评分
高低来进行排序的
那么你的产品只有符合
这几个
榜单的条件之后才能进入这些场景
不然的话你是没有办法
进入这些板块来
获得流量的
比如说爆款
产品我们点击进去 点进去之后
他会有很多种类型 比如说个人和家用笔记本电脑
商务笔记本电脑
他是已经把这些板块
按照属性或者按照他的用途
进行分好板块了 比如说你点这个进去
进去之后就是
个人的和家用笔记本电脑的爆款商品
你看这里是按照
巡盘来排序的 这里是按照
订单来排序的 看到没有 这里都写有
具体的一个排序规则
这里也写有具体的排序规则
这里也写有具体的排序规则 这里的话就不
讲了
那你就按照这个
实录去看
下面这些也是
细分的一些
品类的一些榜单 下面这些地方都有
在接下来的这个板块新品上架
也就是说
你的新品
如果符合平台新品规则的时候
那么你的产品就有机会在这个模块展示 那么我们看里面
具体的看
你要符合
这几个板块
那么你就有更多的新品展示的机会 这里的行列内幕来到更细分的属性
这样一层一层的找产品
所以说我们发产品的时候
也要把我们的属性填写完整正确
因为这些都有可能决定着你能不能
进入到某些榜单 能不能获得某些榜单的一些流量
或者是某些场景的流量
或者是系统把你分类的是否准确
都很重要 所以一定要在标题关键词
还有属性上面描述清楚
最下面这个板块的汇采购
主要就是通过报名去实现这个位置的流量
你只有符合条件报名了才有机会被圈品圈品了里面再进行
二次排序
比如说你有入围的条件
满足了那么你的产品就有机会进入汇采购这个
活动里面进行参与排序
排在越靠前那么你的流量越好
通常来说
你排在前20名的流量是非常好的但是呢
如果你
右围的但是你的本身产品数据很差
在这个活动里面排在很后面
那么他也是获得很少流量的
还有这个板块180天内最低价格
如果你符合这个条件也参加了
一些报名的都会有在这个这些里面
就是按照这种展示就可以了
是一样的逻辑你可以自己去浏览看看哪些板块
你不懂的或者是说哪些板块你还不熟的
无端的去看细分一点去细致的看
这个板块的话系统根据你的偏好给你推荐的这些板块
有些时候这里是会变的也就是说它不是一成无变的
它是会根据你的偏好
或者说系统已经根据当前活动给你推送的
这些都会变化的下面的话就是一些推荐的产品
推荐的产品就是根据千人签面啊或者是说你在这里经常收收多了那么是不是就会
在这个里面给你推荐这些内容
第二个板块就是制造商板块制造商板块的话主要就是以卖家为主
在这里展示你看一个卖家
可以
提取三个产品来展示这三个产品是系统根据
店铺里面
效果
比较好的来
展示在这里了
我们点进去就可以看到产品跟对应的供应商
这里的话基本都是靠
交易额非常多的
才能够在这里展示的
这里是一商带三个产品
就是这样
我们还可以从这里看类目
这个板块跟产品的板块
点进去之后
里面这些每个都是一样的
还有这些每一个
场景
你只有符合条件的才能够进入
比如说准时交货
快速响应时间
唱销品
报款产品
保留趋势
新品发布
这些你店铺里面越多满足这些场景的
那么你被抓取
进入这些场景去排序的机会就更多
所以我们为什么经常来看一些平台的规则关于这些场景流量的一些圈产品的规则呢
就是为了想让我们店铺里面有更多更多的产品
能够被
系统全选到
进入这些榜单
或者是进入这些流量的场景
进入了之后呢它会有非常非常多的流量的
你不要小看这些这些板块流量都是非常大的
非常多的人在这些地方点击去看
和浏览的
所以说这个板块你一定一定要重视起来
同时呢
你一定要去把前面的这些首页的结构理解清楚掌握清楚
这样的话
你在运营店铺的时候
思路就会非常清晰
你想要哪些地方
有流量
想要哪些地方
进入更多的流量
才能够让店铺
的整体
效果更好
这些都是非常重要的
所以一定要重视这个板块
这节课我们就先讲到这里
下节课我们再见